a few months ago I had a brilliant idea
I'd make a tribal gate stack with child
of Alara as the commander
I'd run 55 lands along with a bunch of
drawn ramp with maze's end crackling
perimeter and a handful of Beatdown
options being by wincons
a plethora of ways to sacrifice child of
Alara means that I should have board
control mostly handled so I only need a
mere five slots of the deck dedicated to
interaction of all types how efficient
finally a few options for Big Life gain
means that once my land count is up
where I want it I can heal up the damage
it took me to get there
it's not a high caliber deck but it
certainly scratched my goofy deck itch
and it seemed pretty solid for what it
was
unfortunately it was a terrible idea
chiefly because of the commander
now allow me to lay my credentials on
the table
I am a cruel control player at heart
my first commander deck was mono black
ruin your day with children as the
commander
my first deck I played with at
sanctioned events was a standard grix's
control deck I built just after the
release of born of the Gods
and my favorite draft I ever played in
was the dragons of tarkir draft where I
picked up five flattens and seven other
removal spells and spent my night
gleefully watching The Joy drained from
my opponent's eyes as creature after
creature bit the dust immediately after
it was played
so when I tell you I want a commander
that just repetitively bore wipes to be
a good idea I mean it
but it's not a good idea
in the context of Commander boardwipes
are a type of effect that I would call
asymmetric
this is confusing on the surface because
they're generally literally symmetrical
effects you know they destroy everything
but what I mean here is that they impact
different players massively differently
somebody playing a low to mid-power
synergistic mid-range decks will feel
them very brutally but there are a lot
of types of decks that just won't really
care as much
board wipes won't stop combos they won't
prevent Aggregates from abusing your
life total they won't slow down large
land counts and they won't shut down
your opponents generating a lot of
instant and sorcery based value
the best option my child of Alara deck
has for dealing with somebody suddenly
winning is using one of the two counter
spells within the deck or preparing to
instant speed sacrifice child of Alara
and hoping I don't encounter interaction
of any kind
okay so the child of a large dependent
game plan has some holes
big whoop I'm playing a gate stack man
no my deck has some weaknesses
however this is a bigger problem than it
seems
going back to the idea of the car being
asymmetric we can think about how it is
experienced by the Decks that are more
vulnerable to it
and the answer is it's hell it sucks so
hard for these decks they can barely
even start to build a board before
they're staring down the barrel of
another child of alarisac
even if they deal with one of my wipes
as long as my ramp game worked out as
intended there will be another one
immediately following it
this is similar to the graveyard decks
analogy from my last video
this deck will ruin the day of casual
Synergy decks but against a less bored
dependent deck it'll putter around and
be a mild nuisance before getting
ultimately crushed with little to no
chance of actually pulling off one of
its wing guns
now child of Lara is the most extreme
example of boardwipes creating highly
asymmetric game experiences but this is
an issue with boardwipes as a whole
I talked a bit about my glitter deck in
my mid-range video and that deck
operates as a kind of homage to the mono
Black Shield red deck I played when I
was 15.
get card advantage on a town of mana and
proceed to throw bombs and one-sided
board wipes at the table until my
opponents fold
now that deck is much more well-rounded
than the theoretical child of Alara deck
it has a lot of single Target removal to
deal with key threats and a variety of
win cons which can all eliminate a
threatening player much faster than
maze's end or crackling perimeter
nonetheless the profile of how it fares
against different decks looks very
similar
I try not to pull out the deck against
the low to mid-power mid-range Decks
that make up a decent portion of the
decks in my play group because it
generally Stomps on these decks in
Theatrical fashion
however when my opponents have pressure
to prevent me from fully greeting out or
counterspells for my massive Mana
Investments or combo wins to catch me
and my mostly sorcery speed removal
Suite off guard it's much worse against
these sorts of plays my deck ends up
looking like one of the clunky mid-range
Decks that I usually Crush
before going further I should take the
opportunity to state that board wipes
aren't bad overall
a lot of decks are heavily board based
and it's good to have a solid way to
deal with that
a better version of my glissa deck would
probably be running three to five board
wipes instead of eight with tutors to
bridge the gap but years spent as a
model black player forced me into the
hard truth that unconditional tutors are
bland as hell so I don't play them
ultimately the deck is what I want it to
be and I'll happily let it serve as a
teaching Point as happily as I'll play
it the real thing I'm trying to convey
here is the need to be mindful when
constructing your deck the interaction
package of your deck and what things is
particularly good or bad against is
something you should think about
ideally it should be well balanced and
if there are holes they should be
intentional rather than incidental
as an example my Marriott equipment
stack has very little hard removal burn
and non-creature permanent destruction
yes but not much for big creatures
this is mostly a matter of the fact that
I'm playing an aggro deck and I'm
looking to get a substantial board
presence early and be threatening life
totals
the next removal serves to slow down my
opponents and deal with pesky cards like
Dragon Predator but ultimately the next
solution to later threats is to Simply
deal with the player or politic around
the threat for a while
my Dex removal Suite has a hole but it's
a calculated one
another common hole in an interaction
Suite would be fast blue Decks that
choose to almost entirely run counters
that don't Target creatures a choice
motivated by the fact that most forms of
interaction from their opponents are
non-creature and in essence scatter
isn't going to help protect a Turn 4
combo win
as a final note let's return to the idea
of asymmetric effects
a lot of stacks effects and hate cards
also fall under this label
but Stacks effects generally operate the
opposite way as board wipes choking out
burst view strategies that carefully
plan out their resources to execute
specific game plan while having less of
an effect on a deck whose game plan
consists of play tree folk or something
there's a reason why running a bunch of
stacks effects is a better idea than
running a bunch of board wipes The
Source detects shut down by an archon of
America are generally stronger and more
carefully constructed than the source of
decks shut down by a plague wind
you can build a deck with a bunch of
stacks effects and a win plan that can
outrun a mid-range deck but you can't
build a deck full of board wipes with a
win plan that can outrun a combo deck
and if you build a deck that massacres
casual mid-range decks but flails around
against everything else you're going to
be struggling to create interesting and
dynamic games